we begin this half-hour with a Father's
plea to the president a Tennessee man is
hoping to catch president Trump's
attention this weekend and raise
awareness about a safety issue that
changed his family forever CBS News
transportation correspondent Kris Van
Cleave has the story my daughter Hannah
I'm worse was fatally impaled by a
defective Lindsay X Lake guardrail Steve
I MERS paid $1,000 to run this message
in West Palm Beach during the Super Bowl
hoping the president is watching at his
Mara Largo resort it was worth taking
that shot to see if maybe the president
will see this I MERS 17 year old
daughter Hannah was killed when she
struck an X light guardrail in Tennessee
in 2016
instead of collapsing on itself as the
device does in this company video police
say the rail acted as a spear
penetrating the driver's door hitting
Hannah in the chest and head nothing
prepares you to be the parent of a dead
child and to discover that well one the
nature of this accident was horrific at
least 13 deaths nationally may involve
x-lite guardrails this video shows
another Tennessee crash that killed 69
year-old Wilbert Byrd in Missouri this
crash killed 59 year old George Jansen
Eimer says federal regulators have been
slow to act it's one thing to lose your
child to an innocent accident but we
lost our daughter to a defective product
and to see the Federal Highway
Administration be this dismissive it is
it's insulting the Federal Highway
Administration says safety is the top
priority and points to new more
stringent safety criteria that went into
effect in January but lawsuits claim
there are more than 14,000 X lights on
us roads nationwide since I MERS death
Tennessee has begun removing its
guardrails complaining of installation
deficiencies and ten other states now
say they too will get rid of the X
lights in a statement to CBS News
Lindsay Transportation Solutions says
the X light has successfully passed
crash and safety tests in accordance
with federal standards and notes no road
safety equipment can prevent injury in
every crash scenario for CBS this
morning
Saturday Kris Van Cleave Washington